we know that met young men have a hard
time in dating so a lot of men will come
to the conclusion
um I want to I want to wait till I'm
older to get married so I have a little
more love
there are guys that just want to make
sure they don't ever slip up because the
idea of them being abstinent for 15
years if you want to sell that to men
good luck okay it's like yeah you have
to be abstinate until you're 35. okay
um so a lot of guys just don't want to
take that risk now it's interesting
because the majority of vasectomies are
reversible but the majority of marriages
fail so why is one so triggering but the
other is not and if you say that's a bad
idea you're ashamed you've been sold the
dream that kids like if you kids are are
the passage to happiness and I would
agree if they're your kids but in the
west the children are not yours men have
no legal rights